Nate Burleson is with us NFL Network
good morning football co-host and you
can follow him on twitter at Nate
thirteen Burleson also see him Monday
through Friday NFL Network's good
morning football at 7:00 a.m. Eastern
from Times Square how are you Nader I'm
good I'm good it's the perks of being
the New York little rail Rick Pitino
Urlacher I don't fit in that group no
you're one of our favorite guests but it
was great and then the fact that we can
have a locker in here at the same time
you're in here yeah because you two had
how would you describe your relationship
or lack thereof
we had some battles and at one point I
thought I hated Urlacher you know when
you're young and you're in an NFC North
the black and blue division you're
taught by the oh geez that you're
supposed to hate every other color every
other team in Urlacher because he is so
good he is so dominant I always want to
embarrass him more than anybody on their
team because you know if you knock off
the head the body's gonna fall so if I
can make him look like a fool
there will be no confidence in their
squad and I was a dancer now I was that
guy that will go over the top and he'll
tell you I'll catch a two-yard first
down and I'm bumping in their safety got
up later I'm looking like Kevin Hart on
stage and he would always get so mad at
me and I remember one game in particular
I dropped the swing route and it hit my
fingertips and I'm doing one of these
like turn it and I'm walking it out and
he was like hey 13 where's their dance
and I'm like look at your big ass dance
he's 65 and he did a little shimmy and
it made me so mad like I don't know why
even to this day I was like why are you
mocking me cuz he was the quiet one he
didn't do the trash talking but I can
tell you when to get under my skin and
he did and I remember the rest of that
game I'm like you know what I'm
embarrassed I'm embarrassed it's DB's
and I caught a ball shooked DB ran out
of Bounce and I ran directly to him and
I'm in his face I don't want to fight
him of course cuz I probably could beat
up but I'm like yeah all game low baby
so that would happen over and over again
I remember I broke my leg in Chicago and
I tried to get up and I collapsed and it
was like one of the movie moments from
like I don't want these dudes to see how
weak I am I'm gonna make it off this
field by myself try to get up again and
I crumble and my trainers come over and
they help me off the field and then
somebody says eight
we know you're tough let him help you
off the field and I'm thinking it's
coming from my side and I look over it
it's Urlacher and I was like damn like
Otto Otto Otto while I thought I didn't
like this guy and then he had a pass in
his family I believe it was mother and
the middle of the game this is like a
year later I said hey man I'm sorry
about your loss he looked at me said
thanks and I got that point I was like
such nonsense for guys to get caught up
in the rivalry because it's so much
bigger and now he's one of my favorite
men in general any time I get to see him
on TV any times he comes on the show
it's like a brother it's like a brother
that you fought when you were younger in
elementary and now you guys are
extremely tight so yeah I'm proud of him
and for him going into the Hall of Fame
it means a lot because I know that I
played it beginning some of the great
some of the guys with this game would
you rather face Ray Lewis or Brian
Urlacher
I would rather face Ray Lewis because
Ray Lewis was a bigger frame he might
have been faster and a little bit more
powerful
Urlacher was more versatile in the sense
that I was afraid to go up against him
if he was covering me because of his
length his catch radius and his ability
to cover deep downfield I knew at some
point if I got Ray Lewis downfield
I could probably expose him and his
covering ability not so much or lacquer
that his range I'm talking sideline to
sideline going on a goal I was like no
other and he rewrote a position that is
constantly rewritten yeah which is odd
to say Nate Burleson NFL Network good
morning football co-host the highlight
of your NFL career was what the
highlight of my NFL career was helping
make Detroit relevant again you know I
got drafted by Minnesota those days were
great you know I remember them handing
me a check for $500,000 and I was like
oh baby I made it this is what you do
with it I'll put it right in the bank
actually I got the the athlete starter
kit which is the Escalade in the fake
chain that was some of the oh jeez is
like don't buy anything real until you
can afford it and then I went to Seattle
which was great because I'm from Seattle
and I remember them handing me a check
for a million said 2.6 on I was like nah
man we made it again
then a sign of Detroit and that check
was a little bit bigger and that was fun
but it was more than the money because
two years prior they were only 16 a year
previous they were 2 and 14 and I
remember a player that lock on the day I
signed said I thought I thought it was
thought it was a rumor you understand
this is the funeral for God's careers
like I didn't believe that she was sign
here why would you sign here out of all
places I'm looking at this do it in my
head I'm thinking they pay you bro buy
you sign you sign up to represent this
city in this organization you're here on
Sundays and they're cutting you a check
and I had to like change that mindset in
that culture and they we did some guys
out they brought in some guys and now
like Detroit they don't look at
themselves as the armpit of the NFL and
I know it's kind of cyclical so it
happens with certain teams right now I
think the Cleveland Browns are in the
midst of that which is why I can
appreciate a Baker Mayfield who says
yeah I want to go there like I want to
be part of something because if you can
if you can change the complexion of how
a team is viewed and the perception of
themselves like you're a legend forever
even if you don't win you're a legend I
spent four years in Detroit I was banged
up more than I would have wished I was
unfulfilled number two to Calvin if I to
stay healthy of course I'd have been
better but because I was invested and I
was referred to to Calvin Johnson and
ran number two to Randy Moore and Randy
at their peak it was better at their
peak that's a tough question
at their peak I would say Randy Moss
pump more fear in guys if you break down
like just pure ability who do you want
how do you want I want I want I want one
Randy Moss I want okay but it's closed
it's closed because the reason that I'm
thinking so much make you're afraid to
say Calvin Candie might blow you up
right now
no no this is what I said if who would I
want because Randy was so explosive limp
expedia limp Expedia's Calvin was the
more well rounded white receiver he
could block better he is more physical
at the point of attack if you ran Calvin
across the middle he's gonna try to run
over your linebacker in your safety and
then score a touchdown
you ran Randy Moss over the middle he's
gonna catch the boy he's not gonna take
that big shot but Randy's space was that
umbrella to decent defense he took that
top off every time but the fear I would
I remember being in the slot and looking
at Randy as we line up and he was
standing erect like completely up it's
it's a verse to what we're taught as
wide receivers you get low
you're like a car coming out of the
gates and as tall as he was the DBS were
so scared no exaggeration see the white
of their eyes see their hands trembling
and not to see their toes lifted up off
the ground toes which means in their
head they were thinking oh I got to get
out of here and they were already on
their heels and I would look at Randy
and he'd be looking at me like damn
right the plant even started yet and I
got him beat tell me the logic of Jalen
Ramsey calling out all these
quarterbacks
it's Muhammad Ali it's Floyd Mayweather
its Richard Sherman yeah but they won
things it's true but the the great ones
they called the shots and then went out
there and walk the walk and I'm not
gonna call him a great one but you know
how bold you got to do to call somebody
out before you even did anything
initially I was like you're out of your
mind young pup what are you doing I
remember talking crazy to Steve Smith
and Steve Smith is like top five
craziest person on earth and Steve don't
play deep don't steal to this day he
doesn't play Steve's on the show the
other day I was like we need to pull his
mic cuz he gonna curse any minute but
that's my daughter it's like my brother
right there but I remember thinking like
Jalen you better respect the legends but
then I start thinking about it aside
from paying homage once when you see
somebody as a man how much respect do
you home after that like when he went on
GQ and he start college quarterbacks and
they're like Nate isn't that
disrespectful how is it disrespectful if
in his eyes is true he's talking about
Eli saying he lies nothing Ronaldo do
what he saw last year it might be true
and all these other quarterbacks do you
think five years are now ten years from
now
they'd waste a breath talking about the
greatness of jaylor magazine so why does
he have to hold back what and what he
thinks is true so the old man in me the
grumpy old dude on the porch says young
pup respect og cuz that's how I was
taught but then I thought to myself
don't concede like that you don't have
you don't have to you don't have to I
know it's not PC but you don't have to
and I got to be honest with you Dan I
felt like there was a law
part of my career where I did too much
of that playing with Randy playing with
Calvin I talked about all the time I
made a living off of being their Robin
and I was fine with with watching Batman
go to work and kick an ass all the time
but what if I would have been a little
bit of a jerk what if I asked for a
little bit more money what if I don't
want it a little bit more to spotlight
instead of making you know a few million
I would have made 40 or 50 million some
of these guys they call their shot and
they talked themselves in a position of
power the question is can they follow up
all that talk by walking it if your wife
comes out in a dress and she says do I
look fat you don't say you look fat you
say you don't want maybe a different
color so Jalen is being honest but that
doesn't mean I don't give you extra
credit just because you're honest this
is true but then you know what what
bothered me the more the most he wasn't
honest about Blake bortles you're right
if he's honest about Blake bortles I hey
he made my job easier that that week I
had a lot of things to say but if you're
gonna be talking about you know Matt
Ryan and all these other guys in Eli
Manning and then when the topic is Blake
bortles and then you say well you know
he's good in the playoffs he told that
line he told that line he said he's good
in the class Blake does what he has to
do I think the new generation and this
goes for a lot of these Millennials
especially when it comes to music I mean
look at some of these weird hip-hop
artists like these guys don't care about
the the lineage in the in the history of
hip-hop like you ask a dude now today
who's selling all kind of records and
got all kind of streams you know what's
your favorite biggie album are to party
like I don't know I've never listened to
it some guys in the league now
basketball football baseball they might
not necessarily care about what happened
two decades ago and I can't be mad and
what are we gonna do a in your free time
hey go watch some NFL Films now I can't
force them to do that I remember Russell
Westbrook everybody was saying oh you're
a Cali guy you got a love Kobe when he
first got a league he was like Kobe's
good like you know like he's not my he's
not my idol I don't have to call him my
idol if I don't want to and I think
that's what some of these young guys are
saying like you know III want my idols
to become my rivals I don't want to hold
them up on a pedestal my whole career
the colomac deal Oh
that is their locker here sure is
oh there you know you guys are good
though you you and Nate are good right
that's my dog
didn't used to be good but you guys are
good now we had some good battles okay
so good battles okay
he gave us some good but weapons well
where was I
a clue Mac okay Khalil Mac deal yeah
explain it from the Raiders point of
view why this makes sense what makes
sense because they're trying to win
right now I think the the the
misconception about teams would a young
quarterback is that they're building and
they're rebuilding it for so long they
didn't have the pieces the running game
struggled and then they got Jordan
Howard and Tariq Owen and then the wide
receivers like where's Kevin white they
shipped out Jeffrey and and Brandon
Marshall what are they gonna do and how
they got those pieces they added in why
receivers tight in play and of course
they've been loading up on the deep
inside the ball and even Worldcon smith
me and your guy you add on a fixture oh
I love what the Bears did fixture oh
yeah what are we doing what are we doing
here and this isn't a shot to grew
because I'm not that guy to see to take
shots at coaches I was taught better
than that but if you making a hundred
million dollars your quarterbacks making
over hundred million dollars you go talk
to a dude that is a hundred million
dollar man and that's Khalil Mac and for
a Gruden say oh you know I haven't
reached out to him yet I haven't talked
to him yet what are you waiting on
that's the first phone call you're gonna
make even if you know that the situation
is bleak and it might not turn out right
hey how you doing Khalil what can I do
can I take you out there can we talk and
we rap how can I make this better we
need to figure out a way to get you on
the squad it just doesn't make sense
when you have a dominant guy as dominant
as him and you're letting them go now we
can all say that you know three years
from now if the Oakland Raiders load up
that they wanted to do but right now at
the surface I feel like the Chicago
Bears are winning in more ways than one
I like what the Bears are doing I think
the defense I liked him before this but
this is all based on true Biscay you're
rolling the dice on true Biscay because
if he proves to be a franchise
quarterback then this is gonna pay
dividends because you get that rookie
contract for a quarterback and now you
can build a team just like Seattle did
right just like Seattle did carson wentz
right and then
but that's it right it's it's what are
they gonna do now in that nagging system
they're gonna open up that playbook let
them go out there all of a sudden the
NFC North oh man it's really sexy some
of the storylines with that Kirk Cousins
all that money Minnesota wagon and they
got it let's be real they gotta win the
Super you got to go to the Super Man
Stafford that's my dog I played with
them man hey where you at man are you
are you a top-five quarterback can you
will your team to be better than other
three quarters is that you're supposed
to be better than and can you go take
the throne from Aaron Rodgers and
speaking of riders the boogeyman is back
in Green Bay and I you know it for what
it's worth
people think I hate on the gray Packers
and maybe there is some ill will because
they kicked our bus too but I don't
think that it's a shoo-in that Aaron
Rodgers is gonna have the Jordan effect
and all these pieces all of a sudden are
gonna play incredibly well this division
is too loaded for it to be that easy
it's not as easy as it used to be for
Green Bay
give me the quarterback you'd like to
catch a pass from past present I really
love what Carson Wentz did last year
weight of all the quarterbacks Carson
wins because his ability to extend a
pocket and he has that weight like Joe
Namath or Joe multi-time my father is
from San Francisco so it had to be Joe
Montana so like my heart was always in
San Francisco being a West Coast kid we
used to drive down 14 hours from Seattle
and a Bronco deep six of us and I would
go down there and I would think about
putting on those colors and Joe Montana
to me he was a god of the game have you
met him
no never met him large on my 10 don't
show up unless the check is involved
cement the Hall of Fame just saying
hashtag just saying maybe if you work in
some Skechers commercials on your show
you're right I'm mama hook him up some
sketches cuz he loves those things yes
he does
I know he gets them it's mr. sketcher
he's Nate Burleson NFL Network good
morning football co-host and you can see
Monday through Friday NFL Network good
morning football 7:00 a.m. Eastern from
Times Square Nate great SIA buddies I
appreciate it for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel two three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]